and a potential breakthrough for those
experiencing vision loss as the FDA
approves what is a new drug 8 news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough spoke to
locals about the impact the drug could
have on those who need it in the valley
it's the first and only FDA approved
treatment for the advanced stage of
macular degeneration Mary Trujillo a
chronic dry ice sufferer watching a
story on this very topic as the FDA has
introduced cyphrovray a drug now
available to the masses that can help
hinder the progression of macular
degeneration which is the leading cause
of blindness among the elderly sit back
relax a moment ophthalmologist George
Parr with the Nevada Retina Center is
able to provide this life-altering drug
to his patients here in the valley the
latest iteration is now this brand new
drug that we're all excited about which
is called pegsita Copeland or siphovere
I was involved in a number of clinical
trials over the last few years and we've
been waiting for this opportunity and
while this drug doesn't make a person
See Clearly again it does slow the
progression down of retinal thinning in
the trials that were conducted
the patients didn't gain Vision they
still over time slowly lost division but
at a slower rate and that is a big deal
for people Trujillo agrees this is
something she could definitely benefit
from I have to wear these glasses
because with the age the Gen the
generation it was visible I can drive
I can read I decide that I need to do
something and I went to see the doctor
and the doctor did some treatments but
it didn't help and it's when they say
that I need surgery